well the original title that was was uh
suggested at the beginning was is stoic
theology useful a devil's advocacy
argument and I thought well I don't want
to be a devil's advocate and I think
we're going to get a lot of stuff about
stoic theology so I'm going to shift the
topic slightly given the overall theme
of of the conference which I I really
think is quite good there's you know
this notion that religion or belief in
God something you know and quite
encompassing offers Comfort or meaning
to people and you know the question is
can can stoicism do the same so I think
that's a really great question and it
opens up the possibility for you know
doing some comparison between
stoicism and the things that we
typically think of as religion so I
decided to shift Focus to what we could
call analogies kind of in seneca's sense
where it's not exactly like a ratio or
something like that but we get a grasp
on something by seeing
matters you could say in their native
habitat and this this question about
stoicism and religion in a very very
broad sense comes up endlessly in the
Facebook groups if any of you
participate in those you see that stuff
coming up a lot I imagine I don't
actually check out stoicism Reddit but
it's probably showing up there as well
so I think there's a lot to talk about
and I think we're going to hear a lot
about that from other people in this and
there's a lot of other related topics
connected to this the compatibility
between stoicism and varieties of
religion so I thought we could you know
Begin by thinking about religion itself
and there's a lot of complexity and you
could say moving parts and distinctions
and interconnections and similarities
between what we typically lay able as
religions and what we nowadays also call
philosophies of life or if you like you
know Alistair McIntyre's term tradition
constituted rationalities there's a lot
of ways of talking about this and
stoicism fits in there quite well
there are some you know identifiable
philosophies of life that people see as
coming out of religious Traditions
um you know you could think about uh
Confucianism or Buddhism but there are
you know very secular versions of these
as well and you know if we think about
historically the use of Epictetus by the
monks and the monasteries who took the N
Caribbean and very you know I think we
all know this story changed Socrates to
Christ and the philosopher to the monk
there's an adaptability there and they
were also reading you know Seneca quite
a lot
um they're getting a lot from Cicero
from the neoplatonists and so there's
this this very rich kind of soup
historically that we can talk about that
has a lot of ingredients to it and I
think one of the things that could be
very helpful is in thinking less about
trying to find things very carefully
because as we're going to see there is
no consensus definition of religion and
thinking in terms of a Greek term that
we're all familiar with in its English
version heresy which comes from high
races which originally means a choice
and a choice of what a choice of your
philosophical or religious or whatever
other kind of commitments and so it was
it was quite common to talk about you
know stoicism as being a heresis just
like epicureanism was or neoplatonism
was and you could also think about you
know religious practices that way as
well and I think there's so when we
think about it that way there's a lot of
overlap and we can talk about the
meaningfulness for people who are
practicing it as something that draws
them in now as I mentioned there is no
consensus definition of religion anybody
who like tries to quote a dictionary a
definition
is you know
they're they're overlooking the fact
that within religious studies just like
in philosophy as well in philosophy of
religion there is a whole variety of
definitions we almost have too many of
them and nobody is entirely on board
with with these and the same thing it
goes for Philosophy by the way it's kind
of an embarrassment that philosophy
there's too many definitions of it and
the philosophers themselves don't agree
on it you could say the same thing for
uh psychology for emotion for all these
important terms so maybe we get away
from worrying over too much about
definitions and we think instead about
well you know what are the what are the
things that we typically associate with
religion there's a number of different
Scholars that we could turn to ninian
smart is sort of a common place with his
seven uh dimensions of religion
doctrinal mythological ethical ritual
experimental institutional and material
real and if we look at how stoicism is
practiced or we look at it's it's uh you
know development over time I think you
can you can see some of these figuring
in there the ethical is of course very
important you can ask if there's a
doctrinal Content I think that's quite
clear that there is as well although not
everybody agrees on precisely what it is
um you know you can talk about a ritual
a dimension to it definitely
experiential particularly when we're
getting together in groups there might
be an Institutional aspect to it I mean
there are groups out there and and uh
important we could call them
institutions within largely the the
internet sphere
um you know so there's there's room for
looking at connections or similarities
between stoicism and religion and smart
is just one of many people we could
bring up you know if we had much longer
time we could talk about William James
and the varieties of religious
experience and whether we could talk
about varieties of uh stoic practice and
groups and you know things along along
those lines
when it comes to stoicism we're probably
better off we don't have a definition of
it I mean there are people out there who
are like give a give an elevator pitch
for stoicism and those are nice as
elevator pitches but you know like
Seneca points out to us stoicism is a
complex set of
self-reinforcing and referring ideas and
you know you're not you know if you try
to encapsulate it in a single formula
you're not you're not getting that much
but we can certainly say there are some
things that are stoic and some things
that are not stoic right if you say for
example pleasure is the only good okay
not stoic Epicurean or otherwise
hedonists but clearly not stoic if you
say something like virtue is the only
good well you know that's definitely
there is important it's not the totality
of stoicism but it's a good start
and um you know when we think about
stoicism and its emergence within the
Mediterranean and and near East World in
Antiquity and then its encounter with
all sorts of other let's call them ways
of life or ways of thinking you could
you know you can say that stoicism was
viewed as a rival not just by other
philosophies but also by uh religious
people in their communities and their
their Traditions you know we can
definitely see this in Christianity
where the early church fathers
constantly talking about the stoics uh
you know think about lactancius and his
uh treaties on Divine anger where the
stoics and the epicureans are his main
opponents and interlocutors Jewish
authors even you know Pagan authors of a
certain sort you could think of like you
know the the Pagan neoplatonist
tradition which draws heavily on
stoicism and Aristo italianism you know
simplicus's commentary on epictetuses
um and karidian a lot of talk about God
in that right so you know the stoics
were were viewed as being were they
religious uh yes and no I mean
there's Providence as we're going to
hear about uh shortly but there's not an
awful lot of personal interaction it's
not a way of life in which prayer plays
a fundamental role I mean Epictetus
talks about God is caring about
particulars but he might be an outlier
when it comes to that there is this
beautiful idea that you see in Epictetus
and in Seneca of a commonwealth or a
political Community which is the world
of human beings and gods so we are
connected with the Divine in some way in
classical stoicism it's not like the
gods show up
as in Greek fables in Disguise and hang
out with us or anything like that but
there is this sense of of community that
matters
um there's also this sense of there
being a bit of God within all of us I
mean Epictetus is super clear about that
that's why you shouldn't treat people
badly uh not just you're screwing your
own little bit of God up say when you go
to the house of prostitution or do other
bad things but you know when you when
you mistreat your neighbor you're
messing around with this this bit of God
and you know is that the same thing as
the you know icon uh Theo or the you
know Imago day not exactly but it's
pretty close you know and there's some
similar ramifications obviously there's
a huge overlap in terms of Ethics the
four cardinal virtues which gets some
really great discussion in stoic attacks
are definitely not unique to the stoics
the platonists even the epicureans you
know recognize those and that's taken up
by Jewish and Christian authors as well
you know the focus on the will and
what's up to us we're going to see that
as as Central in many different
Traditions moral development is is very
important
um you know and we can also talk about
what is what is the end what is the the
goal you know if it's something like
Tranquility or getting along with people
or having a meaningful life or something
like that I think there's a lot of
overlap even in ancient stoicism with
with uh all the other things that are
going on the other hyrues as we were
calling it earlier and if you think
about
um you know our contemporary
concerns you know there people talk
about modernity as being a time not just
of secularism which doesn't actually
seem to be uh you know quite so easy to
take for granted these days at least
here in in the United States
um but also being a a time in which we
have this meaning crisis right people
are having less meaningful lives and I
think a lot of people are thinking that
stoicism could could help out with that
and probably probably rightly so
um I think you know here's where we can
ask well what do people take religion to
mean and then we can say okay what what
things are stoicism doing or providing
or offering that would fit into that and
um you know it's clear that not only is
there no consensus about what religion
is among the you know scholars in
religious studies or philosophers of
religion or sociologists of religion
it's very clear that people all over the
place Place have a whole bunch of
different ideas about what religion
means not just in general but for them
what does it mean to be committed to a
religious life and so I put together a
kind of typology that might provoke some
interesting discussion of ways in which
people live out or at least think
they're living out their religious
commitments and I think we could see
some of the similar things in in
stoicism uh at least you know within the
vast stoic community so there are some
people who are very pragmatic you know
and experiential and they're like I just
want to try this thing out I'm not going
to commit in any major way until I see
some fruits and you know people do this
in in churches and you know synagogues
and pick whatever else you want and I
think there's a lot of people doing that
with with stoicism uh it's sort of like
and they look for the entry points what
we often call the gateway drugs as we're
introducing people to it and then at the
Other Extreme there's what I call the
immediate convert the person who runs
into something they're like holy crap
this is amazing I can't get enough of
this right and they jump into it uh
wholeheartedly and very often with you
know you could say blinders on or the
proverbial uh rose-colored glasses
sometimes that manages to sustain them
for a while sometimes they uh they get
burnt out on it and I think we see
people doing this with with stoicism as
well
closely related to this would be the
people who basically treat religion as
if it is
you know their Community is their
in-group and everybody else is in the
out group and religion becomes you know
just another set of group dynamics and I
think there's people like that with
stoicism they're on team stoic and um
sometimes they actually misrepresent
what stoicism is because they haven't
studied it enough but they you know they
want uh they want a very strong division
between the stoics and then like you
know say those dirty epicureans or
whoever else right
um we also have people who you could
call in in religion we call these Church
Hoppers right or church Shoppers right
and I think people do this with with
philosophies of life as well they try
one out and they're like yeah not for me
go to another one and they just keep
moving from uh place to place so to
speak and commitments
um and then you know all of these are
not bad I would say one that is
you know I I guess we could call it bad
I'll I'll leave it up to you to think
about this people who are in the group
sometimes they like to police everybody
else you know and these are the people
who are chiming in constantly and saying
that's not stoic of you you know and
you're like well who the hell made you
the the uh King of the stoics as Seneca
might say right
um and you know is this like what
happens in religious organizations or
political organizations or any other yes
of course so so there's certain types we
have evangelists people who are
um you know turning now to groups
outside or individuals outside they've
got this great you know thing that they
want to share with everybody and they're
constantly doing that I think we can say
there are stoic evangelists of of that
sort there are the Insiders or
institutionally Associated people the
ones who keep everything going the ones
who see the how the proverbial sausage
is being made and takes a certain kind
of stomach to do that because just as
with any other organization people are
not always living up to the ideals that
they profess but we we you know to put
on a conference like this it's work
right so you have to do that and then
you know before we go into too many
others because I could go on and on
about this there's one other group that
I I think is is worth bringing up where
there's kind of an interesting analogy
and I hesitate to call them stoic monks
and nuns or ascetics but I think there
is something kind of like that a
recognition if you think about what what
did the original
ascetics want to do they withdrew from
society not because they're like well
society sucks screw it all they're like
I you know I need some peace and quiet
and some being able to concentrate on
what I'm trying to do with my life you
know with the monks it's an orientation
to God so they can pray better and maybe
make themselves um less miserable
bastards that they come in as stoics
maybe there's less prayer but there is
also an emphasis on the damaged beings
that we are and trying to slowly improve
this and maybe you know evangelization
would be a distraction or policing
others would be a distraction and I
think that this is a very important part
of stoic life for for many people I mean
I could say I know people who who behave
like that they're they're not usually
the ones doing a lot of organization
right they're they're trying to withdraw
and just practice this stuff now can we
can we draw analogies to different ways
in which people live out their their
religious lives and say that you know
these are possibilities for stoicism as
a philosophy of life I would say
definitely
um they're not exactly the same there
are some vital differences which we we
certainly can't explore but I think it's
worth thinking about all of these
different types that we we encounter
right and figuring out where we fit into
these as well I would say I'm probably
when it comes down to it because of my
involvements over the last years I've
been one of these sort of
institutionally oriented people and
that's actually taken time away from
practice and study you know that I'm
kind of looking forward to getting back
to as I pair back on on some of those
commitments so so does anybody have any
uh questions about this kind of
disorganized proposal
yeah I think that loosening boundaries
is is a good way to talk about it I I
will throw in one other thing that I I
didn't quite say I mean I don't think
that stoicism needs to be made into a
like rival religion I think there's
enough space that
um you know being a philosophy of life
is already enough right it certainly has
some in its classical form it certainly
has some what we would typically call
religious commitments meaning about
beliefs and you know a providential
ordering of the universe or things like
that but um
you know how did you put it uh we don't
have to have like barriers or we don't
have to maybe in other ways thinking is
we don't have to have like
identification you know so stoicism
doesn't need to like shift over into
this thing that we we call religion uh
in order for it to be very very helpful
and useful and and to provide meaning
for people's life I mean I don't think
you necessarily need to be a religious
believer and committed and you know
practicing all the time in order to have
a very meaningful life and I I would
suspect that for a lot of people it
actually does get in the way you know
depending on how how it's being played
out so
yeah that that um I mean that might be a
perennial Temptation for some character
types right to to get
um
get into everybody else's business
because it takes away Focus from your
own right the more time that you're like
telling other people oh that's not stoic
of you or you've got things wrong or
something like that the less time you
have for like looking at how screwed up
you are and how to unscrew yourself up
using stoic philosophy
and I will admit that I myself have
succumbed to that Temptation from time
to time